now before the games into bogarts
well he forgot something from his sweet
upstairs so he needed some help
from his suite mate raffy devers and
martin perez were both up there
trying to help him out the toss landed a
little short he had to go get it
behind the netting you don't see that
every day
and another 3-2 from austin both
walked up so rafaela's out
see you there's a high deep drive sucked
way way back
off the light standard
and the x-men strikes again his eighth
home run
that is an absolute cookie and he just
destroyed it
get that tower out of the way so we can
get the tape measure on that thing
hit the other way in a line drive giving
chase and missing it is eaten
it'll be up against the bullpen fence
and chugging into second pillar he's got
himself a double career double number
200.
so plowecky will bat up the middle base
hit
pilar rounding third he's going to be in
to score and the red sox will lead to
three to nothing
second consecutive ball game the red sox
have done that to washington
to center jbj to dive and make the play
well maybe not one of his most
spectacular efforts but he timed it
perfectly
easy catch for him yeah it's almost like
he made a circle to make that catch
so two down a man in scoring position in
front of rafael devers about a long at
bat
in the first inning and eventually took
a rare walk
there's a high fly ball and that one
backing up the right fielder
still backing up still backing up can't
get it
and the baseball is where
where did it wind up
and that ball is out it is gone that's a
home run
and here comes rafael devers around to
score
the weirdest home run trot you're gonna
see from devers
but the wind is blowing dead out to
right field you got to remember
so debra's with a two-run homer to make
it five to nothing
back-to-back singles and now comes juan
soto
soto base hit to right victor robles
heading home turner to third and just
like that
some guys with bats but then that's
going here the lines moving and they're
on the board who has drubal
into left and maybe that brees knocking
that one down but trey turner is coming
home
and just like that the nats have two on
the board well this was earlier today
brock holt the newest member of the
washington nationals
celebrated on the big board at fenway
park for his six seasons
as a very popular very productive player
for the boston red sox
and typical of brock with no fans in the
stands
taking a bow and the imaginary applause
well you know people would be given a
standing ovation right now
yeah he was such a favorite he was not
just with the fans the players loved him
kevin plewecki an rbi single in the
first inning
raising his average to 353. get to a
whole lot better than he's done as a
backup catcher he jumps on that one a
high fly ball
driven deep to left field that's going
to be off the monster
pilar pounding around third he's going
to score
and plawecki has a double to drive in
his second run he's been terrific with
the bat
and that is bobby dalback and his major
league debut
i just have a feeling like his first
major league hit is going to be the home
run
and a fly ball into right field pretty
well backing up
near the wall he can't find it where is
it
that ball is gone that is a home run
eaton completely lost it
and bobby dulbeck has homer to right
field
in his major league debut boy that wind
is
torching to right field i've all skied
and
got up in the wind and it carried i
went way back that wasn't even in the
first row
so here we go top of the fourth harrison
garcia and robles
on a pitch up josh harrison jumping all
over it
outfielders watching see
you later it hit just above the monster
above that yellow line rattling around
out there for harrison second homer this
weekend
his third as annette thames are grounded
to the right side and a fly ball to left
thames waited on that one skying it deep
to right
center see you
later eric thames second homer is
annette
both on the road atlanta and now boston
i wouldn't throw a lefty anything to
pull right now i don't care if the
monster's there or not
and a meeting pulls one right field way
down by pesky's pole
hits the ground and deadens gomes around
and adam eaton is heading for third with
an rbi triple
it's eight to five daniel hudson comes
out of the bullpen for washington
denver's
he's had a couple of really long at bats
today this is the 10th pitch coming up
in this one he scoffs that one but
down the line whoa did that one wickedly
little hesitation move that ball is gone
that ball is out of here that's a little
hookage
a wicked shot by rafael devers down the
line into the corner
and a home run fastball up out over he
just snaps this thing
out of here rice trying to finish it
runner at second
and a high pop-up bogarts and now coming
behind verdugo
and he'll make the play well that's a
fitting end yeah
to this ball game he had a lunge at the
end to make it what a wild one
red sox win it nine to five